well as the federal government
distributes the vaccine president trump
says it's up to governors to get the
shots
out to their residents this is the
highly contagious uk strain is now
in the u.s with the first case appearing
in colorado so how is it
how will that state plan to stop the
spread let's ask colorado's democrat
governor
jared polis governor great to see you uh
thank you very much for being here happy
new year we are
all concerned of course about this fast
spreading faster spreading
version of kovid what's the latest on
your
ability or inability to trace where it
came from
so you know at this point uh we were the
first to uh find the variant here in the
united states it doesn't mean colorado
is the first to have it we think it's
in probably in most states they've since
founded in florida in california
it's not yet the prevalent strain
meaning as we
detected and looked at the strain of a
number of folks who had coronavirus and
sadly we have two or three thousand a
day here in colorado
coming down with coronavirus uh it's
still just a minority of cases we've
just found uh two tentative
identifications one confirmed we expect
to confirm the second soon but what
happened in the united kingdom david
is it very quickly because uh this is
what led to the conclusion and it
spreads more quickly it very quickly
became
the dominant strain in certain areas
crowding out other strains because it
was more contagious
well have you been able to find out
whether it was something that that
mutated here in the united states that
grew organically in the u.s
war was imported from the uk uh most
likely the latter um i don't think
scientists will know definitively for
some time but it's unlikely
i'm told that a identical strain would
mutate twice the same way so
there's a lot of commerce and travel
between united states and united kingdom
people go back and forth between
new york and london and san francisco
and denver and texas and london almost
every day so
it's no surprise that it wasn't kept
successfully isolated there well thank
god we have vaccines available but there
there
are problems with the vaccines they
we've got about 12 million doses that
have been made so far a lot more coming
online but
of those 12 million doses i'm told only
about 2.8 million have been administered
where are the log jams so the vaccines
are a godsend thank goodness and here in
colorado we're prioritizing age 70 and
up people 17 up or receiving the vaccine
as as we speak it'll take about four to
five weeks at current supply levels
for everybody stepping up to receive the
vaccine
um i'd put a couple points into that uh
here in colorado what we did is we said
anybody that we partner with to
distribute vaccines and that means
hospitals
community health clinics uh others need
to use every dose we give them
within 72 hours or we will reassign it
to somebody else who will so we had to
use that kind of
firm hand to make sure that the doses
are getting out as quickly as possible
the other issue is a somewhat erratic
weekly supply from the federal
government
it's hard to to book patients to know
how many we're giving when the
quantities change
not not they're not like doubling or
going in half but when we get oh it's 30
less well we have to cancel those
appointments or roll them into next week
and try to in the following weeks so
we're hopeful that there's more
reliability on the weekly supply from
the federal government well and again
thank god we have them as you as you
first noted
there there is some irony here in that
some governors not not you but some
governors like governor cuomo have
have objected to directives coming from
washington he even
formed his own little fda his state-run
fda to
approve of the vaccine not trusting the
one in the federal government
but when it c when it comes to
complaints about
distribution of the virus he's all for
directives from washington
there's a contradiction there isn't
there well i haven't
been listening to what every governor's
been saying but i for one am very
grateful that we have the flexibility to
prioritize age 70 and up here
um the cdc put out recommendations 875
and up what we found in colorado
is that 78 of our fatalities from
coronavirus
are age 70 and up so once we get through
that group we can reduce fatalities by
three
quarters and that's really why we're
focused on 17 up and then we'll go to 60
to 69 after that
good for you good for you i think most
americans agree that's
how it has to be uh prioritized governor
polis we wish you the very best in not
only tracing this new virus or the new
mutant
uh but in also getting the vaccines out
thanks for coming in and happy new year
to you
always a pleasure having you here dave
thank you very much